[Music]
in porn
she'll news submitted by simple fire
[ __ ]
oh this I like I you know Marlene maybe
sale under fire for moonlight as a poem
actor one male porn or night one that
means that's your other job your side
job like if you moonlight as a doctor
that we keep working at another hospital
all night you do that mm-hmm so bad day
he fights for the country at night he
[ __ ] for the country that actually
makes a lot of sense though why well so
a lot of like Navy SEALs because it's
such a high level like stress
environment a lot of more adrenaline
junkies so people are trying to seek
that extra stimulation so I can see why
they're like like I think what the
typical
stuff doesn't work for them like you're
like I don't want unnormal I don't want
to go home but to watch TV I want to go
home and take viagra and then bone
people Wow you think that is just
passion project or if you think that he
needs money so he's doing a second job
just robbing some job I know is this is
this simultaneously or he's a former
Navy Seal and he's good with this genius
boy oh [ __ ]
yes and a lot of energy mm-hmm Joseph me
Joe says he's 42 years old from San
Diego hum Diago Sandhya is a 42 year old
Navy SEAL so he's been in the Navy SEALs
for a while for 23 years he's any
military he's a navy chief Special
Warfare Officer Wow he has been Sailor
of the Year many times he is a public
speaker and a recruiter for maybe he's
so he sounds like all of them badass yes
anything box you just be numerous
ribbons and medals including a valor
citation for combat overseas
he's also the face of the seal program
on its website that's time so they had
some [ __ ] too
this is what he looked like and he's
artistic
you can that's Marcel he aka myself so
he when he's moonlighting as a porn
actor he goes by J room and so the
reason why I respected this guy if he's
like yelling in your face you know like
two days later don't smile because you
know what it was good I'd respect them
even more on my damn this guy's not only
a warrior but he's also talented in the
sexual arts and I might be intimidated
for gay porn ok so ok portion so he's
made over 30 porn films so yeah 2010 Wow
and so he's been doing these mostly with
his wife who is a porn star although
Wiggins why make sense does porn stars
wife's name is Jules Jade and whatever
[ __ ] the most ridiculously yeah
they've been married for about 15 years
they do have children I don't know how
many kids they have together though but
so Jules was the one being interviewed
about the story because her husband did
not want to make any comments to the
media so what she was saying is that she
had been doing porn on and off since
2001 when she stopped doing it as when
they got married and started having kids
and stuff they ended up but they needed
by a soccer fan so he was I'll just go
back to making someone money no so what
happened was that they started a real
estate company together in Virginia but
then two years later the company went
under they went bankrupt and so they
needed to make more money that's when
she went back into doing porn and so in
order to save money on like hiring
actors she just enlisted her own husband
to do it so then that's why he has been
doing all this porn [ __ ] all these other
girls because it's for them money
honey I'm doing this for us but she was
her idea yeah so it seems like she
should put these together sir if she's
talking about saving costs on yeah
laughter that's cool she's a producer -
she's been doing more than 240 films not
her not her vagina but other people's
I'm not sure is just says that she's
done 240 plus which is obliterated yeah
so she's saying that her husband never
wants wore the uniform in any of the
films and they never did like a navy
kind of quarter and I'm pretty sure he
wouldn't do it yet so the wife says that
the field and his commanders already
knew about his moonlighting but she's
not sure why now all of a sudden they're
starting an investigation but it's kind
of an interesting timing because he's
eight months away from retiring and so
this is now when this invasive
investigation is beginning and so I give
him his money maybe because he is at
risk of losing his pension that's [ __ ]
up he put in twenty years he's let him
chill the [ __ ] out
yeah and so they're saying like he's
facing disciplined for violating the
rules that require field to request
approval from a commanding officer
before starting any outside work and so
they're saying that maybe a maybe
spokesperson said that he was granted
permission to sell herbal supplements
but not to do porn and so he like they
were also mentioning and in in the
interview that the reason why he did a
request permission to work as this is
because most likely would have been
denied anyways because the Navy and it's
like a lot of other military they're
saying that they they forbid activities
that prejudice good order and discipline
or that is service discrediting risk
potential press or public relations
coverage or create an improper
appearance
so obviously that would fall into that
he's a [ __ ] warrior what a [ __ ]
do you care
yeah so this Anwar Sotto's kid if if
your oh my god if you're getting paid
for the government from the government
to go out there and [ __ ] shoot
kill and be a goddamn warrior you should
be able to do well the [ __ ] you want
well maybe I mean I really think like
having your military background you
think that they should be able to do
whatever they want or like no you can't
because you're involved in a lot of
top-secret missions
oh it's the same thing it's the same
thing as being like a CIA or FBI special
agent so you're probably going to go
undercover and do a lot of like covert
ops and you can't be having like they're
the ones when they interview you they
usually blur out your face change your
voice so because of that you can't
really go in a public forum and just go
out and do stuff like that but um yeah I
don't know it's it's pretty crazy though
that like I just feel like for the kids
like on one side or dad's American war
hero and then your mom's a pornstar
crazy it's not like I'd be so conflicted
as a kid like in my family yeah it's
like with the wife like she's she's
constantly saying she's a military wife
and like I knew about this and not only
that but she was actually invited well
that was on her evening gown at the
White House she said that she got it she
was invited to go sign autographs for
the field back in 2011 Oh like they
already like there and honestly no I
just think it kind of stuck where they
going
I think that's a white house well this
is a charity dinner and I think it just
sucks that he had eight months left he
put in twenty years and it's like all of
a sudden they want invest again I'm like
he's a war hero [ __ ] it just this let
him be yeah catch another like George
Lopez was like you know he turns up me
there's a Men's Wearhouse - that's the
herringbone dress oh I think he can do
in Jamaica I think you could do well the
[ __ ] you want because he's a warrior I
see a fuchsia pink you could [ __ ]
whoever you want if you want to be a
cowboy everybody else with a dildo
that's not a security breach for me that
tells the enemy that we are [ __ ]
crazy
so [ __ ] you know how crazy we are our
warriors not only [ __ ] murdered
thousands of people but they [ __ ]
know how to be sensual with themselves
that's crazy they're all so [ __ ] sexy
yep there's they're [ __ ] sexy as hell
what's more man than a man [ __ ]
another man that's cream actually right
now really man
yeah but then the wife was on saying
like like why do they even care the
military is like one of the biggest what
is it like the biggest consumers of one
for sure they're the ones that keeps all
the military people saying could be the
jack off dude no it's just hard why they
acting like it's a it's an organization
full of good respectable young boys I'm
pretty sure they're just coming
everywhere that's pretty sure the whole
place knows it come do you make sure
like issue pocket [ __ ] to all these
soldiers I think the ones that are
overseas [ __ ] yeah yeah just do that for
them and also prisoners I think so yes
go keep that attention yeah although we
need the soldiers testosterone up oh you
do really not I think like if I was
their kid
I um I like really wonder like what I
should do for the future cuz you know
how kids like they look up to their
parents and they want to follow in their
footsteps so I'm like should I be a male
stripper or should I be a you know
straight-up
warrior what should i do what should i
do both I'm just worried about his skin
he looks like he's been a skin cancer
she still could he's a white man but
he's so menacing
why I thought it was Latino he does look
like uh his last name is Schmidt
the third is white as well in our skin
is straight of leather that's gonna be
got too much Sun [ __ ] you need some
sunscreen [ __ ] just cuz I'm
trying to help heal you and what did
that are you going to wearing this I
need to know what going on
maybe it's the AVN Awards awesome ABN
yeah you got it going to be an adult's
video it's like the Oscars for the porn
industry I think do not make sense the
violin the what dinner did they go to
where the full breasts are huge by the
way yeah I need my god
they're like two [ __ ] watermelons you
don't be nuts on a UN meeting
imagine all the people like that came
into all these political meetings we
would have world peace we would have
more women right world peace is intended
position just be food or do you think
there will be many many wars if ladies
ran everything no hmm there'll be a lot
of arguing and backstabbing but not war
and no killing no killing promotion and
killing out because girls won't be like
all right I'm going to send all these
tanks to blow you up because even their
enemies they can't kill no no there you
can't kill a person here war we can
destroy the reputation you know what's
interesting when I see somebody with
head size like this and a boulders like
bouldering body he looks like you take
steroids or something he has like that
steroid face it could be do you think we
do they have steroid like drug checks
when you do the military on the military
no there's a lot of guys actually take
oh so they're like yeah whatever you
need to make yourself more stronger well
they don't it I think it's so like
steroids is such a niche in micro theme
that a lot of the people in command they
don't even know about it
so there's like a lot of cops are on
steroids too and they just they don't
they don't know there's people that are
like the ones that are really pulling
the strings 67 year old guys they don't
know anything about sterile is the is
the thing about steroids giving you a
more aggression is that true is that
hearsay it depends on a steroid okay
this is I'm there's a hundreds of
different types of steroids with all the
different things okay but it has
happened
eczema cream that was steroid so I was
on steroids ooh strong Jo I am eternally
cold I'll be wrong that was a funeral
yes what is that you have a go at making
full jack and then you have steroids for
Lance Armstrong was obviously not Jack
but it helps with endurance so there's
like millions what about the kind of
helps you with a strong dick that I
don't know is that steroid it could be
some steroids mixer just makes your dick
bigger and then if you're a girl yeah
you're good [ __ ] turns into a dick I
don't want a bigger dick I just want a
strong one I want to going on Vicky news
fans hope you guys like that episode
remember to follow our
personal social media and of course if
you want to watch more videos might you
tell where to go your [ __ ] right
up there